s'informer comme on peut tenter de
suivre de comprendre ce que vivent les
soeurs des frères des parents à plus de
dix mille kilomètres d'ici ont mis en
marche
l'ex birmanie les yeux rivés tantôt sur
des chaînes basés par exemple
au bangladesh voisin tantôt sur le fil
des réseaux sociaux
[Musique]
on a beaucoup de difficulté à joindre
nos proches précise tap de la mine face
à la mède l'accès à l'internet est
fortement réduit et l'information très
contrôlée depuis le coup d'état du 1er
février dans ce pays secoué par la
répression sanglante des manifestations
qui se tiennent maintenant jour et nuit
de la mine fazal ahmed dit qu'il se
désole d'entendre ses interlocuteurs au
miam à lui décrire à quel point la
situation est difficile là bas ils
apprécient d'autant plus le fait que ces
enfants soient au canada sa fille la
plus âgée est arrivé avec ses fils qui
sa femme en 2016
quelques années avant lui
la petite dernière est née l'an dernier
pour se loger et pour obtenir du soutien
il compte notamment sur le centre
multiethnique de québec accueille ici
ils ont fui les persécutions au myanmar
comme l'ont fait des centaines de
milliers d'autres running à une minorité
musulmane apatrides par vagues
successives souvent pour vivre pendant
de longues années dans des endroits
comme celui ci que nous avons visités en
2017 pour les ronga le retour du régime
militaire ne leur dit rien équivalent
aref ab gomme les pousses de la mine
s'inquiète particulièrement pour sa mère
veuve et isolé depuis le départ de ses
frères seul dans l'ouest du myanmar le
long de la frontière la thaïlande se
prépare à un afflux de birmans un pays
que ce jeune homme connaît bien
sourd et s'y étaient réfugiées enfants
avec ses parents membres d'une autre
minorité ethnique du myanmar québec est
devenue sa ville il y a quatre ans
synonyme pour sa femme ses enfants et
lui de havre de tranquillité
nos portes et une optique c'est pas
comme
en birmanie face à ce qui se passe là
bas il se sent impuissant on a essayé de
l'aider mais vu la taille de la
communauté d'origine birmane un peu plus
de 9000 personnes au canada selon le
recensement de 2016
on n'est pas fort la communauté donne
parfois de la voix pour réclamer la
libération donc sans doute chi celle du
myanmar le retour à la démocratie pour
dénoncer les violences qui ont fauché au
moins 250 vie jusqu'ici pour les sports
tous mes amis me faisais tous mes
proches quand dsk était un avenir
incertain
la junte militaire birmane reste
imperturbable peu importe les
condamnations et les sanctions
internationales
ici numéro un du canada québec